اهلا بكم الى اهم الانباء من قناه الجزيره
في قطر في ختام لقاءات عقدها في القدس
ورام الله شدد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
على ضروره اتخاذ الطرفين الاسرائيلي
والفلسطيني اجراءات لخفض العنف ومنع مزيد
من التصعيد وجدد موقف واشنطن المتمسك بحل
الدولتين داعيا الى الحفاظ على الوضع
القانوني والتاريخي للارض المقدسات
من جانبيه حمل الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود
عباس الحكومه الاسرائيليه كامله المسؤوليه
عن التصعيد والتوتر الذي تشهده الاراضي
الفلسطينيه وشدد على ان الفلسطينيين لا
يقبلون استمرار الاحتلال
مددت السلطات التونسيه حاله الطوارئ في
البلاد الى نهايه العام الجاري وفق ما جاء
في مرسوم صدر في الجريده الرسميه تعد هذه
المره الاولى التي تمدد فيها الطوارئ
ده عرائس التونسيه وقيس سعيد القوات
المسلحه والامنيه والقضاه للتصدي لمن
اعتبرهم متامرين على الدوله وقال خلال
زيارته لثقنه الحرس الوطني بالعاصمه انه
لا يمكن بقاء ما سماهم اعداء الوطن خارج
المساله
اتهم رئيس جبهه الخلاص الوطنيه في تونس
احمد نجيب الشابي الرئيس قيس سعيد بتوظيف
القضاء العسكري للانتقام من خصومه واصدار
احكام كلها تتعلق بتدوينات او تصريحات
اعلاميه واعتبر شابيه من المحاكمه
العسكريه مضره بسمعه البلاد
وبحياده
الجيشين ان الولايات المتحده تستعد لتقديم
حزمه مساعدات امنيه جديده لاوكرانيا بقيمه
مليارين ومئتين مليون دولار واضافت ان هذه
المساعده الجديده تتضمن لاول مره صواريخ
طويله المدى
وصف المتحدث
بولندا ودول البلطيقي بالعدوانيه وقال انه
من المخزى ان الدول الاوروبيه الكبرى لا
تضع حدا لها واضافها بسكوفنادول البلطيق
وبولندا على استعداد لفعل كل ما يثير
المزيد من المواجهه مع روسيا دون التفكير
في العواقب قال وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيبا
ان البدء المبكره في المفاوضات نحو عضويه
اوكرانيا في الاتحاد الاوروبي سيكون
الموضوع الرئيسي في القمه الاوروبيه
الاوكرانيه
المقرره يوم الجمعه المقبل
قالت وزاره الداخليه الفرنسيه ان عدد
المشاركين في المظاهرات الاحتجاجيه ضد
تعديل نظام التقاعد فاقا مليون و4 مليون
متظاهر وترى فقط الاحتجاجات مع موجه
اضرابات عن العمل جميلات عددا من القطاعات
الحيويه بينها التعليم والمواصلات العامه
والطاقته والمستشفيات
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]